it's a new month and the six free games
for July 2016 have been announced
action-adventure multiplayer Aachen /
open-world and even a JRPG game this
month since row guitars of help kicks
off this month collection playing as
Johnny Gat or Kinzie Kensington your
task is to go one-on-one with Satan
himself in this third-person open-world
outing think GTA with less polish and
zero respect for real word logic and
you've pretty much summed up all central
games clocking up a Metacritic score of
65 this would appear the game is not
going to wow you but you never know
until you try the second game on ps4 is
fury and it appears to be a brand
spanking new game this may be a sign of
things to come for future PS Plus
releases fury is a boss fight game in
which you take down a gauntlet of
enemies with massively different
playstyles in one round you may rely on
your stealth or another may ask you to
murder everyone with your trusty sword
remember your favorite boss fight from
Zelda Metal Gear revengeance are even
Devil May Cry while these fights are
lovingly recreated in this quirky little
title please give this one a try we
believe is the game of the month fat
princess is a first title on ps3 first
released in 2004 fat princess offers
online gameplay in which you feed cake
to your princess your task is to kidnap
the other teams princess and as we all
know fat people are pretty hard to
kidnap it looks a lot like Animal
Crossing the childish art style really
has the experience but keep in mind this
is a team game and if you have a
terrible team you have a terrible time
current Metacritic score 79 out of 100
Call of Juarez bounding blood is game
number 4 on the list and originally came
out in 2009 the game is set in the Wild
West and feels a lot like Red Dead
Redemption but in first person the
story's a little obvious and most gamers
will complete this in about five hours
but for again at 7 years old the combat
feels natural and quite a fun experience
Metacritic has this at 78 out of a
hundred over to the massively neglected
Vita now for our final two games first
up is Prince of Persia revelations which
is yet another PSP part from 2004 this
one doesn't feel anywhere near as good
as its PSP counterpart the control
system has moved on so much that it just
doesn't feel correct but one thing it
does serve is
nostalgia for retro gaming probably best
to avoid this one though
IGN gave this six out of ten finally or
ashika or ashika I'm so sorry if I
butchered that name tainted bloodlines
rounds out the multi freebies this is a
Japanese role-playing game from last
year if you're a final fantasy fan this
one is right up your street but be
prepared to spend days weeks and even
months playing this to obtain all the
quest items
this game has a 7800 Metacritic score so
they were our PS plus games for the
month our research suggests that we will
receive in about 68 pounds of content
this month with you Americans receiving
about $92 worth which of this month's
games will you'll be playing please
sound off the look if this video has
proved useful please share and consider
subscribing hopefully see you next time